[Music]
on this Monday night allegations China
interfered in Canada's 2019 election the
fight against foreign influence what's
the government doing about it and
demands to better defend democracy a
global news exclusive increased security
at the American midterms it's a huge
concern plus the longing to find common
ground in the U.S Ontario's Premier
promises to repeal the school strike ban
what it means for students and a
distressed signal about the planet we
are on a highway to climate hell the
un's climate Summit opens in Egypt
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from Washington
good evening from America's capital on
the eve of important midterm elections
in this country election deniers are on
the ballot the Democrats say democracy
itself is on the ballot and though
what's decided here won't change who is
in charge in the white house it is a
referendum on President Joe Biden's
record we'll get to all of that in just
a moment but we begin tonight closer to
home and a global news investigation
into allegations of foreign interference
into Canada's federal election in 2019.
multiple sources tell Global News at
least 11 candidates received clandestine
funding from entities affiliated with
the Chinese Communist Party sources also
tell Global News Canadian intelligence
officials have briefed the Prime
Minister on their findings this is what
Justin Trudeau told us today
unfortunately we're seeing the country's
estate actors from around the world
whether it's China or others are
continuing to play aggressive games with
our institutions with our democracies
Global News investigative reporter Sam
Cooper broke this story our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson is
following it up tonight
they are the kinds of persistent threats
that keep Canadian intelligence leaders
up at night foreign entities acting
covertly to influence and subvert
Canadian democracy Global News has
learned that those very things have
already been happening here with sources
telling us that Beijing is pulling the
strings sources tell global news that in
January of 2022 Canadian intelligence
delivered a series of sensitive
briefings to warn the Prime Minister and
select members of his cabinet that the
spy agency had evidence China was
running sophisticated operations
including allegations of placing Chinese
agents into the offices of sitting
members of parliament and funding a
secret network of candidates who ran in
the 2019 general election at least 11
candidates in total Global News sources
said the network includes members of
both the liberal and conservative
parties some with winning ties to the
Chinese Communist Party according to
sources the funding about a quarter
million in dollars was allegedly
transferred via an intermediary into the
alleged Network and was then transferred
to a Canadian politician an unnamed
member of Ontario's provincial
legislature as well as an election
staffer sources told Global News Canada
is now being targeted more than other
countries and there is concern about how
that could affect our democracy and our
International reputation this is a wrong
message that we are sending to the world
not just to not just to the Chinese
but also to our allies that we are not
reliable that we are not trustworthy
sources repeatedly stressed to Global
News how serious these Revelations are
cease has told Global News it could not
answer some of our questions for this
story but did confirm China's
interference saying in an unusually
direct statement the Chinese Communist
party is using all elements of state
power to carry out activities that are a
direct threat to our national security
and sovereignty sources tell Global News
the briefs also discussed operation Fox
Hunt a program intended to forcefully
repatriate Chinese citizens wanted by
the regime the RCMP has said it's
investigating three so-called Chinese
police stations in Toronto seen here
community members worry about the
regime's reaching Canada clamping down
on Rivals and dissidents we are just
very vulnerable so that's why um I would
like to uh repeat the
urges of um many many other community
leaders and that we need a foreign
agent's registration the Trudeau
government has been warned about
vulnerabilities that have left Canada
exposed for years on Monday the Prime
Minister says he takes the threat
seriously the world is changing and
sometimes in in quite scary ways and we
need to make sure that those who are
tasked with keeping us safe every single
day are able to do that but experts say
the government has taken too long to get
tough there certainly needs to be some
signs that they're going to come up with
some legislative fixes and not just come
out with warnings every now and then
because I think people are getting tired
of it and sources also say that Canadian
MPS who voted to declare the abuse of
the uyghur population in China a
genocide have been actively targeted in
their writings one of so many concerns
about China's efforts to influence
elections here in Canada Donna
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
there are more details on all of this
you can read investigative journalist
Sam Cooper's reporting on our website
globalnews.ca
now back to politics here in the United
States the midterm elections are
tomorrow the Democrats claim democracy
itself is on the line many of the races
in Battleground states such as Georgia
Pennsylvania and Arizona are expected to
be very close and that could lead to
several scenarios early voting began in
October and it has been historic more
than 40 million ballots have already
been cast that's a record
and here's what's at stake Democrats
control both the House of
Representatives and the Senate right now
but by narrow margins Republicans can
retake the house by flipping just five
seats and in the Senate they need to
flip just one seat to gain control
Jackson prosco our Washington bureau
chief is with me here Jackson set the
stage for this crucial vote tomorrow
well Donna let's talk about what we know
and what we don't know based on some
fresh polling that's out there right now
on the question of who would you rather
see in control of Congress Democrats or
Republicans voters are evenly split on
that generic ballot question and on the
question of voter enthusiasm How likely
are you to vote or how interested are
you in voting they're exactly split down
the middle again but the interesting
thing here is that Democrats have seen
their enthusiasm number increase by 10
points in the last few days that
suggests that there is a last minute
surge in interest in voting by democrats
now you mentioned those 40 million
people who voted early that's a number
that tends to favor Democrats and of
course Donna the question is what does
this all look like when you favor a
factor in the in-person vote tomorrow
which will favor Republicans all right
and Jackson I know we talk a lot about
the polls I hesitate to really trust
them it's never clear if they're really
an accurate representation of the
landscape out there what do we think
this time yeah a lot of people have
concerns about what's being captured and
what's being missed right now pollsters
are having a really hard time getting
people to even respond to them right now
and so it's really hard to know how
accurate this is going to be come
tomorrow you know in 2020 we talked
about those hidden voters the hidden
Trump voters and I think pollsters are
wondering who are they missing this time
around
the polls are exceptionally close and
one of the problems with them is that we
have to rely on state level polls for
these Senate races and many of those
polls are getting very very low response
rates in the one to two percentage range
that means there's a lot of people who
are not getting pulled many of these
races are actually within the margin of
error of the polls we have
Jackson some Republicans I know we're
already questioning the Integrity of the
vote tomorrow if they continue to do
that could that actually hurt them this
is a real risk that Republican
candidates face right now is that their
voters are becoming so disaffected so
disillusioned with democracy and so
questioning of the entire process that
they may sit on their hands and not vote
because they no longer think that their
vote matters now we're not going to know
how much of that is the case until we
see the final tally but I think we saw a
bit of this play out in the Georgia
Senate runoff back in 2020 and there's a
very realistic possibility that it plays
into tomorrow night's final results all
right Jackson crossco thank you well
Donald Trump's false claims that the
2020 election was stolen has spawned
something many Americans thought they
would never see there are hundreds of
election deniers actually running for
office according to data from The
Washington Post nearly 300 Republicans
who have denied or questioned the
outcome of the last presidential
election are now seeking office they're
running in nearly every state and more
than 170 the GOP election deniers are
running in districts where Republicans
are poised to win in several States
officials are warning attempts to
intimidate voters and undermine
confidence in the electoral process are
intensifying Jeff Semple went to
Michigan where Extraordinary Measures
are underway to protect access to the
polls
move them away
from the voting process and then settle
those issues these Michigan election
workers are receiving training on how to
de-escalate angry voters I think some
people are apprehensive I think some
people have lost
confidence in the elections as they are
this clerk's office near Detroit doubles
as a polling station the building
recently upgraded its security and for
the first time police officers will
Patrol the area on Election Day the
Township's election Playbook is full of
Lessons Learned two years ago prior to
2020 our interaction with police was was
almost non-existent no and now it is
hand-in-hand emergency planning and
security planning has been a key
function of election planning we were
here in Detroit during the last
presidential election a couple of years
ago when they were counting the ballots
inside this convention center and an
Angry Crowd of trump supporters forced
their way inside that building chanting
stop the count
the crowds banged on the windows and
shouted at workers as they counted the
mail-in ballots including election
supervisor Chris Thomas it really got
out of hand for a few minutes the
retired bipartisan official LED
elections in Michigan for four decades
he's coming out of retirement this week
to help protect the process from
so-called election deniers it's a huge
concern it's a real movement I mean it's
substantial and their vocal and some of
them are pretty clever on what they're
trying to do numerous stop the steel
groups have been training their own poll
Watchers and Challengers some have even
organized armed stakeouts at Dropbox
voting locations making sure that we can
oversee the process that it's done
correctly done accurately this former
Republican candidate was part of the
stop the steel protest in Detroit and
the January 6th Riot on Capitol Hill for
which he's now facing misdemeanor
charges two years later do you still
think the election was stolen of course
it was absolutely like Ryan Kelly many
Republican candidates have made those
election fraud claims a central part of
their political campaigns unfortunately
the city of Detroit have been planned
with election corruption for years in
Michigan Republican candidates for
Secretary of State Attorney General and
Governor all claim the last election was
stolen if elected they've pledged to
change election rules they could also
refuse to certify election results so
that's how the whole system starts to
degrade it's going to be one of these
things you wake up to someday
and you realize that the laws that have
been enacted the barriers that have been
set up the people now running elections
really believe make you believe in what
may today be just conspiracies opinion
polls show voters across party lines
agree on one thing American democracy is
in danger in this midterm it's these
election workers who need a win who here
worked in 2020 who here
oh yeah so a lot of you and show of
hands if you're feeling a little bit
anxious this time
we got them we got this
Jeff Semple Global News Canton Michigan
back in Canada the Ontario government
pulls back its strike ban coming up what
it means for thousands of Education
workers and students
what happens tomorrow in the U.S
midterms could upend President Joe
Biden's agenda we are back from
Washington in a moment
[Music]
more than 50 000 education workers in
Ontario will be back to work tomorrow
their Union made that decision after
Premier Doug Ford said he intends to
repeal legislation that imposed a
contract on the employees and ban them
from striking
as a gesture of good faith our
government is willing to rescind the
legislation we're willing to rescind
section 33
but
only if QP agrees to show a similar
gesture of good faith
by stopping their strike
Global's Colin Demello is following this
story from Toronto Colin the students
will be back in class but two sides are
back to square one yeah in effect that's
correct Donna the two sides have agreed
to put down their political weapons for
now but make no mistake they are
returning to the bargaining Table and
there is no guarantees that either side
will make significant movements there
were a couple of factors that led to
today the premier is facing polling
which shows that parents are blaming the
progressive conservative government and
not QP for the strike as well a number
of unions from across the country came
together over the weekend and they
threatened to hold a general strike on
Monday November 14th and amp up their
political protests it is for that reason
that perhaps the premier decided to back
down and promised to repeal Bill 28 and
the use of the notwithstanding clause we
have our bargaining rights back you led
this movement that showed the people of
Ontario that you can stand up to a bully
look him in the eye and say hell no not
today well I'm willing to put a little
water in my wine I've never been shy to
do that but they need to do the same
thing it's not a one-way Street here
call it not a one-way Street well both
sides have shown they're willing to take
drastic measures do we know what happens
if they can't reach a deal yeah I mean
the two sides are set to return to the
bargaining table tomorrow the premier is
going to repeal the legislation as early
as next Monday but the Canadian unit of
Public Employee says even once that
legislation is pulled back they will
still be in a legal strike position so
if this contract Clash continues the
union is warning they could once again
return to the picket lines Donna
all right Colin Demello at Queen spark
in Toronto thanks the public inquiry
into whether invoking the federal
emergencies ACT earlier this year was
warranted today shifted Focus away from
the protests in Ottawa and to the
blockade of the Ambassador Bridge in
Windsor Ontario
the largest Lesson Learned was not to
let this grow don't let bouncy castles
and hot tubs and sort of those types of
amenities come to the streets on Huron
Church Road and allow this to grow
that's Windsor mayor Drew dilkins he
says despite protesters already being
cleared away he supported the
emergencies act being invoked he says he
feared the protesters would return He
says communication with provincial and
federal counterparts was smooth and
additional police resources arrived
within a day of formal requests that's a
contrast to the jurisdiction and
communication problems experienced in
Ottawa
Ontario Premier Doug Ford and Deputy
Premier Sylvia Jones will not have to
testify at that inquiry they went to
court to challenge the summons to appear
arguing parliamentary privilege protects
them from having to testify Justice
Simon Father Gill says he agreed the
privilege provides the premier he says
and the minister with a lawful excuse
not to comply with the summons since the
legislature is in session though he
noted both Witnesses may have valuable
evidence to offer
Canada's military is investigating the
deaths of a Canadian soldier in Iraq
Captain Eric Chong died in Baghdad on
Saturday the Department of National
Defense says he died under what it calls
non-operational related circumstances he
was operations officer with 38 Canadian
Brigade group headquarters based in
Winnipeg who was part of combined Joint
Task Force working in Iraq securing the
defeat of the so-called Islamic State
new warnings about the planet as world
leaders gather in Egypt for the latest
U.N climate conference
[Music]
put the climate crisis at the top of old
government's agendas or else face
failure that is a warning today from the
U.N Secretary General Antonio guterres
in his opening speech at the U.N cop 27
conference the global conference taking
place in Egypt
we are on a highway to climate hell
without food still on the accelerator we
are in the fight of our lives and we are
losing Humanity has a choice the
terrorists did say the world has the
tools it needs to reduce emissions 100
world leaders will meet over the next
two days many have highlighted that
other world crises such as the war in
Ukraine and inflation have taken some of
the attention and the urgency away from
the need to deal with climate change
WestJet is in major damage control mode
after a system-wide outage caused Mass
flight disruptions more than 200 flights
were canceled across the WestJet Network
the airline says the disruptions are
spilling over into this week even though
the problem has now been resolved
westjet's data center was sent offline
on Saturday because of a cooling issue
customers who had their flights canceled
or experienced lengthy delays are
entitled to compensation according to
Canadian Transportation agency rules
[Music]
America's hopes and fears next the state
of a divided country the night before
midterm elections
you are looking at the Lincoln Memorial
Abraham Lincoln known as the savior of
the Union we're back from the U.S
Capitol in a moment
[Music]
welcome back to Washington this is a
political town but it attracts Americans
from all over the country many drawn to
The Monuments to past presidents whose
leadership built the United States we
went to talk to people about their hopes
and fears for the country
the Washington Monument like the U.S
president it's dedicated to stands in no
one's Shadow it Towers over America's
capital as a reminder that George
Washington the country's first president
set a high standard of leadership we
found people here longing for a return
to Common Ground what matters most
say uh
the economy inflation
the Border this couple lifelong
Republicans don't believe the 2020
election was stolen but does it worry
you that there are people in the
Republican Party who believe that or at
least they say they believe it yeah yes
but I don't think they're the majority
we're lifelong Republicans so until the
Republicans stop denying the election
we're voting with the with the Democrats
just a short walk from here is the U.S
Capitol One couple I met told me what
happened there on January 6th is an
embarrassment what are the countries
looking at us like we're
crazy right now is it a worrying time
for you and and your families most
definitely I have young kids yes
um so I think all the actions and things
we vote for now is going to affect them
this family drove all the way from
Alaska seeing the Lincoln Memorial they
say stirred up a lot of emotion I think
of all the sacrifices that people made
to get us to where we're at now and how
we don't want to lose that and do you
think the United States is
in a perilous
situation right now I do and I think
it's important to realize that
and important to take action
so that we don't come to something that
we regret everyone we met was worried
this man from Kentucky just came from
visiting the Holocaust Museum but if you
go through the whole museum and you
watch the whole rise and I'm not saying
the country is going to nazias and
fascism that sort of stuff but there are
so many similarities in the way that our
political divisions are kind of driving
us into separate camps that there will
never be it we won't be able to be
cooperate and get along and really do
good for the whole American people
everybody
so many thoughtful people out there that
is global national for this Monday I'm
donor Friesen thanks for watching I hope
to see you here again tomorrow when
Americans head to the polls in the U.S
midterm elections for now good night
from Washington D.C
[Music]